Hey, this is really funny.
Just a little bit of a break from the horrible
news.
You might enjoy this.
A bunch of people in the audience have been
writing to me saying, David, you should make
an account on Cameo.
OK, where people can sign up to have me send
people a shout out or troll somebody.
I got a bunch of Father's Day requests from
people saying, hey, please send a shout out
to my dad or whoever else.
They really like the show.
This is all at Cameo dot com slash David Pakman
or your search, my name and the cameo app.
I got an absolutely hilarious request from
someone whose friend, I guess, bought one
of these online Karisma classes and paid six
hundred dollars and his friend was concerned.
So here's the here's the message that I sent
him.
Take a look at this.
Hey, Matt.
So I heard from Casey that you spent six hundred
dollars on an online Karisma class.
Now maybe you're very wealthy, and if that's
the case, that's fine.
But in my experience, you can find a lot of
that material for free.
And I would even be glad for you to call into
my show when I'm taking live calls and talk
about what I'm told is maybe a desire to improve
some dating skills.
OK, so with total peace and love, you want
to figure out a way to get on my show.
You can e-mail me through my Web site.
We'll figure out your phone number so that
we take live calls.
I see your number pop up.
We can talk about what's going on.
It's free.
No.
Six hundred dollars for an online Karisma
class.
And hopefully, hopefully you'll come away
with something just as valuable.
OK.
So I want to hear from you.
So I'm serious.
I actually want to hear from Matt.
I hope that he will call in.
I didn't realize that people actually paid
for online charisma classes.
I guess I should have realized that because
they've been around for a while.
Someone must be paying for them.
But I would love to have Matt call in to the
show.
We can talk about what's going on.
But maybe the funniest part about this is
that someone thought that I would be the right
person to go to for advice on charisma and
maybe dating, which I don't know something
about that is actually even funnier.
So now also I've gotten some requests on Cameo
that I had to turned down people trying to
get me to say.
You know, anti-Semitic stuff and all of this
other stuff.
So so some are being turned down, but it's
a pretty fun platform.
You can send me requests in the app.
I am David Pakman on Cameo or you can find
me at Cameo dot com slash David Pakman.